[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute was veganes
vegan welche disziplin ja gibts auch
nicht oft aber wenn dann wird richtig
richtig köstlich wir machen heute die
kräfte und viele von euch kennen das
jetzt vielleicht die das nicht kennen
das ist so eine schöne masse aus burgos
richtig tollen orientalischen gewürzen
paprika und tomaten mag das zeige ich
euch gleich alles im einzelnen aber ganz
kurz noch mal zur geschichte denn die
kräfte heißt eigentlich rothkötter
köpfte ist ein fleischgericht das heißt
eigentlich kommt da rohes fleisch rein
aber ich mache das ganz ungern mit rohem
fleisch ich persönlich würde auch gar
nicht essen
denn ich mag es einfach nicht falls ihr
das mögt dann ist es natürlich
geschmackssache aber hier gibt es vegane
ski kräfte damals in der türkei gab es
auch immer rohes fleisch im team kräfte
aber das wird dann irgendwann verboten
und seither machen dass in der türkei
auf ganz ganz viele ohne fleisch und ich
zeige euch jetzt zuallererst mal hier
die zutaten die sind etwas speziell aber
die bekommt ihr alle das hier ist zum
beispiel joghurt und das ist extra die
kräfte league burg und das heißt es
steht auf der verpackung dass das für
die kräfte geeignet ist und dass sie ist
die braune variante das sieht dann
einfach schicker aus hier habe ich ganz
viele gewürze dass es hier ist ganz
typisch das ist auch etwas scharf und es
gibt es natürlich auch zu kaufen da wo
in den ball wohl herr bekommt er bekommt
ja auf jeden fall sollte er hier habe
ich jetzt kümmel und zwar etwas gemeiner
kreuzkümmel kenia
hier haben wir ganz normal pfeffer und
seiten der klassiker außerdem edelsüß
paprika mag hier habe ich noch paprika
flocken die sind bei mir nicht scharf
und zu mag das kind ja schon von meinen
älteren videos hier habe ich außerdem
tomaten dann geht's weiter mit rapsöl
und olivenöl paprika und tomatenmark und
außerdem knoblauch so die zutatenliste
ist fast zu ende wäre es fast geschafft
hier geht's granatapfel sirup auch für
mich unverzichtbar und später kommt das
auch noch mal oben drauf aber das zeige
nicht gleich alles in ruhe dann habe ich
hier noch zwiebeln wie habe ich
abgewaschen damit das nicht so scharf
ist
und natürlich ganz typisch petersilie
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal anfangen
die zubereitung in jedem rezept gibt es
auch hier ganz viele verschiedene arten
zubereiten ich zeige euch natürlich
meine und die die mir am besten schmeckt
und dafür nehme ich jetzt hier mainburg
und den habe ich ja schon in meine
rührschüssel gegeben
wie wichtig ist die muss wirklich
ausreichend groß sein und jetzt habe ich
hier heiß auf gekochtes wasser und das
gebe ich jetzt darüber und will das
schön um
[Musik]
nach dem umrühren mache ich den deckel
drauf und gibt dass für ungefähr zehn
bis 15 minuten an die seite aber wir
haben nur alle hände voll zu tun
ich sage euch jetzt nämlich den nächsten
schritt mit den zwiebeln und ich habe
vorhin schon erwähnt dass ich die
zwiebeln abgewaschen habe unter fließen
ganz normalen lauwarmem wasser damit
einfach diese typische schärfe raus ist
wenn weil wir es ja nicht anbraten und
das so bleibt ist diese schärfe meiner
meinung nach etwas unangenehm und jetzt
ist ganz wichtig dass wir das ganze
schön reiben nicht schneiden sondern
wirklich reiben damit die flüssigkeit
heraus kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
obwohl man sagt er mit mund auf wenn man
mit mund aufatmet dann muss man nicht
weil das quatsch und der zwiebel sagt
den müssen wir jetzt raus pressen dann
nehmt euch es ganz einfach eure hände
und prestin so richtig schön guck mal
wie viel herauskommt das gehört aber
alles nicht in unser team kräfte befasst
das aber heute abend ich bewahre den a4
tue ich tue ihm den kühlschrank
ja aber ehrlich ihr müsst den saft also
nicht wegstecken dass er voll schade tu
dir doch einfach in eurer suppe only de
oder
[Musik]
zwiebeln sind erledigt als nächstes
kümmern wir uns um unsere klubs unsere
süßen kleinen knobi freunde ich brauch'
ich habe das wissen alle
und den habe ich jetzt auch noch richtig
schön da rein
mein kleiner freund die knobi reiber und
nicht nur für knobi sondern auch für ihn
war
den knoblauch übrigens nicht ausbringen
mit den händen das müssen man nicht und
jetzt gebe ich die zivil knoblauch masse
hier einmal zu unserem burg genauso wie
alle anderen zutaten schmeißt es einfach
rein bis auf die tomaten bekommen noch
nicht zum einsatz
[Musik]
ja
um
die petersilie die ist noch hier drüben
die kommt auch erst gleich zum einsatz
und leute ich habe noch nie so eine
menge in der küchenmaschine geknetet ich
bin gespannt
dann machen wir das live experiment und
wenn das nicht klappt dann muss ich
einfach erst die eine hälfte kneten und
dann die andere irgendwo ins kleine
anmerkung normalerweise macht man das
unserem geriffelten blech das ist so
typisch türkisch aber ich finde man kann
sich das auch wirklich sparen man kann
es machen dann kriegt man ein tennisarm
und die krampf ohne ende
aber ich mache heutzutage ist ja so
schöne helferlein dass sie macht das
jetzt heute in der küchenmaschine
[Musik]
es ist geglückt geglückt ich jetzt nicht
gedacht weil das ist echt eine heftige
menge aber es hat geklappt das habe ich
jetzt gute neun bis zehn minuten lang
geknetet allerdings auf niedriger stufe
und das ist auch schön
jetzt hat sich schon so verbunden es ist
aber noch trocken denn wir haben unsere
tomaten ja noch nicht dazu gegeben ihr
könnt jetzt entweder tomaten dazugeben
oder eiskaltes wasser mit heißem wasser
machen wir jetzt nichts das war nur am
anfang für den ball wird jetzt machen
wir noch mit kaltem wasser aber ihr
könnt auch alternativ tomaten nehmen das
mache ich nämlich gern für den geschmack
aber wenn ich jetzt keine da hätte dann
hätte ich auch wasser genommen
und die haut brauchen wir jetzt nicht
das ist nämlich kein schönes gefühl wenn
man darauf weist ich nehme jetzt
wirklich nur quasi dieses innere dann
ist das eine richtig schöne saftige
masse setzt geben wir das mit zur masse
und je nachdem natürlich wie groß oder
wie kleine tomaten sind müsste halt
immer schauen entweder mehr oder weniger
oder ihr hilft einfach mit kaltem wasser
nach wichtig ist dass diese masse nicht
trocken geht aber ich werde jetzt gleich
merken machen gleich auch mal so die
stichprobe mit den händen ob es genau
richtig ist oder nicht
ich habe jetzt noch kaltes wasser
zusätzlich zum masse gegeben
keine sorge ich schreibe euch die
genauen mengenangaben wie immer unten in
die infobox einfach aufklappen
screenshot einkaufen gehen und dann
könnte das nachmachen
und hier können wir nicht inzwischen und
die petersilie die habe ich natürlich
gewaschen und getrocknet und dann nehmt
euch jetzt am allerbesten ein
wiegemesser weil wir müssen das so
fahren wirklich so fein wie möglich
kriegen und das geht eben am besten mit
diesen regeln es war einfach hin und her
schwenken
[Musik]
wir haben unsere petersilie pulverisiert
richtig klein geworden ja wir haben sie
nie geholfen hat dass ich sie dann am
ende des videos und ja wenn man mit 2 r
ich ziehe mir ist aber für nächsten
schritt handschuh an weil jetzt borchen
gefühl mit den händen einmal den teig
anzufassen und zu schauen aber schon
fertig ist
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir fertig und das war
auch gar nicht viel arbeit er habe
selbst gesehen und jetzt könnt ihr
entweder das ganze sofort form wenn ihr
das auch sofort zu erwähnen möchte oder
wenn er sagt ich habe sie zum morgen
vorbereitet oder aber für übermorgen das
hätte sich nämlich im kühlschrank total
lange also wirklich so um die fünf tage
dann gibt einfach frisch alte vorher
drauf und formtest dann wenn ihr das
sehen möchtet ich habe jetzt hier noch
ein bisschen auf und zeigt euch dann wie
ich die form mache ja das sind jetzt
unsere fertigen die kräfte das ist die
typische form und anders ist es gar
nicht möglich ihr müsst genau diese form
machen und dafür nimmt ihr euch einfach
ein bisschen was und dann hier kommt man
dann kommt mal dann sei kaum heran haben
sie hier einfach so zusammendrücken und
fertig nimmt immer so viel wie in eurer
handinnenfläche passt wenn ihr zu viel
mache ich jetzt mal als paradebeispiel
wenn ihr zu viel nimmt man das macht und
macht es so dann sieht einfach nicht
mehr los denn ist das zuviel und jungen
zu viel also im merkel je nachdem wer
also die kräfte gerade zubereitet ist es
jemand großes oder jemand kleines so
unterscheiden sich dann halt auch genau
von handfläche herren und was nicht
fehlen darf ganz ganz wichtig
salatblätter und ich finde das so auch
ganz schick aber was ich auch sehr schön
finde ich euch mal dass man die
salatblätter die müssen natürlich
gewaschen sein das ist auch sehr wichtig
dass man die hier unten drunter liegt
uns dann schied kräfte obendrüber
serviert
kammern macht keiner
das ist tradition das ist einfach kult
ur diese vorhaben wir ernsthaft diese
form ist für mich reinste kultur einfach
wenn man zum beispiel in die türkei
gehen oder selbst in deutschland in
geschäften genau dann im urlaub ist es
natürlich auch so gewesen oder auch hier
man hat so einen großen berg mit chip
datei und dann ja das ist ja nicht jetzt
einige pohlers für uns eine große menge
ja dann nimmt man sich da so ein
bisschen was noch kommt dass man klickt
der kunde das und ihr könnt das übrigens
auch so machen wenn ihr zum beispiel
sagt übermorgen gäste bereitet das ruhig
vor und macht frischer gefror
draufpacken kühlschrank und dann wenn
sie kommen am vormittag im dann kriegt
ihr da schnell zurecht das ist ja echt
schnell gemacht
[Musik]
na gut gegangen war beispiel auch nicht
mit essen so kommt der sagt besser raus
du bist so ein paar mal hoch und runter
und ich kenne ich kann euch die
reinlegen
ich wollte nur sagen es passt doch sehr
gut zitrone dazu aber auch noch eine
andere soße die zeige ich euch jetzt ein
augenblick schneiders tritt zurück
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich euch noch eine blitz
soße dafür benötigen wir tomatenketchup
stinknormalen tomatenketchup und der
kick der kommt jetzt durch unser granata
posieren
der kick und der trick und natürlich
gibt es auch in meinem shop
aber ich will auch so froh dass ich euch
das zeigen kann weil sonst habe ich
immer das berufsleben des paars in
schüsseln umgefüllt und euch gesagt ja
canada pension und vielen gbagbo gibt da
so kann sie es kaufen und ich bin so
froh dass ich euch das jetzt ganz locker
flockig zeigen kann und ich weiß ihr
könnt bei mir bekommen und jetzt gehen
wir einfach granatapfel sirup in unser
ketchup und husum und das kommt so was
leckeres bei raus glaubt man gar nicht
aber nicht also üblich ist jetzt nicht
ich habe mich mal unterhalten mit einer
die bei dieser kette gearbeitet hat und
sie hat mir gesagt du bist doch mal aus
und habe ich ausprobiert und war lecker
hat richtig gut geschmeckt
[Musik]
überall wird es schon dunkel und ihr
könnt natürlich auch ihr könnt auch cool
das machen wir doch sonst auch pure
granatapfel sirup darauf geben dass
schmidt auch drohte deswegen hast du
dich jetzt gewundert weil sie zeitlich
ist man alleine ausprobiert und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr hier jetzt ein
fachressort oder studiert und dann habt
ihr auch scharfe soße maxi schaffen
wir mögen die menschen
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon mit meinem
video habt ihr nicht gesehen wie einfach
das ist ich weiß von draußen gekauft
schmeckt auch sehr gut schnitt auch sehr
sehr frisch und das ist auch wirklich
mein allerliebstes facebook wenn ich mal
draußen dass es selbst das ist
eigentlich fast ja wenn es draußen kalt
ist ein gesundes sehr gesundes fast food
und ich finde der schmeckt mir noch
besser wenn es selbst gemacht ist was
sage ich jetzt auch nicht nur so es
schmeckt einfach viel viel besser und
ich kann den schärfegrad selber
entscheiden das finde ich bei mir
persönlich immer ganz wichtig vor allem
kriege ich auch eine maße für zugegebene
machen weniger geld wirklich gar nichts
gegen diese fast food ketten die das
zubereiten aber es schon wirklich den
geldbeutel und ist doch schnell
nachzumachen und jetzt müsst ihr einfach
die infobox auf klagen wie schon gesagt
dass ihn alle genauen mengenangaben
kauft ein macht's nach schickt mir fotos
mit dem hashtag hübschen postet sie auf
facebook und instagram und wir sehen da
haben sie ja also ich bin mir überlegen
ich habe eine riesenmenge gemacht haben
sagt für morgen 14 seiner freunde
eingeladen
und deswegen habe ich so viel gemacht ja
ich finde das ist so eine
haushaltsübliche mengen
was meint ihr ich schreibe euch die
mengenangaben für exakt dieses brett
einmal in die info box war das so machen
das ist doch eine super menge
ich schreibe euch für 28 13 die kräfte
die menge in die infobox sehr guter
einwand und euch jetzt noch einen
wunderschönen tag schreibt noch
unbedingt in die kommentare was sie
denkt wie findet ihr die kräfte mit ihr
das mit oder ohne fleisch schreibt mir
auf jeden fall mal rein es würde mich
sehr interessieren
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal wieder auf die ski zu
[Musik]
euro
ja sag mal ja das ist aber ja sowieso
schon die die sicherheitsmaßnahmen aber
schöne beiden jedes so viel das ist ja
schon geschätzt aber das messer ist
sauer scharf deswegen übernehmen der
nächste schritt haben das video
übernimmt und nicht nach feierabend
[Musik]